there are two different schools of
thought when it comes down to
opportunities there's one community
these are a lot of motivational speakers
that'll say things like if you missed
out on an opportunity don't worry about
it
life is abundant with a number of
opportunities now the ones around the
corners like missing the bus if you
missed three 330s around the corner it's
gonna be alright
don't stress out about it that's one
community here's the other community you
ready this other community says in your
lifetime you're probably gonna get a
couple big opportunities that are gonna
present themselves could be a meeting
could be a sit-down
it could be a interaction with somebody
that you could impress the person where
the person goes back and says I want to
do some kind of business with you that
one opportunity could completely change
your life don't screw it up be prepared
for that's one school of thought who is
right I'm at a story here
it's 2012-2013 NBA season the Miami Heat
are facing off the Pacers that year the
Pacers were very strong they had a
strong Center Hibbert and they're going
against each other Miami has LeBron
Dwyane Wade Chris Bosh and this is a
good matchup they go into playoffs game
1 Miami against the Pacers there's only
2 point 2 seconds left on the shot clock
Pacers are ahead 102 to 101 the game is
in Miami if Pacers win this is a big
statement to the world and it hurts
Miami because they beat him in their
home what happens with 2.2 seconds left
the coach I know this because he's a
Laker coach not Vogel he says should
take hipper downs he sits him down I'm
like what are you doing him disguise
playing incredible defense you got to
keep him in he takes him up inbound pass
to who LeBron James by the free-throw
line
LeBron turns around goes in for the
left-handed layup with 0 left on the
shot clock
they win the game everybody's jumping
all over the place after wards
commentators are talking and everybody
says well you know it's this sometimes
happens but they got to come back and
this one you got to be mentally tough
and this buddies over their data and I
bet the coach and the locker room he's
probably saying this what do you think
the coaches say in the locker room we're
gonna be alright we can make the
recovery Kenny Smith turns around was a
two-time champion with the Houston
Rockets with a Kim Olajuwon he says the
following thing here he says I don't
know if I agree with you guys so what do
you mean
I just don't agree with you why not says
look to assume that you didn't go back
to the finals again it's very naive he
says I have a lot of friends that I play
basketball with for a long time great
basketball players and they had a chance
one time to go to the finals and win and
they didn't and they thought they were
gonna go back and many times they never
ever went to the finals ever again and
they never got a chip and the name of
the game is getting a chip never won
back again i sat there I'm listening to
Kennedy saying wow pretty powerful
statement little bit demoralizing not
the most optimistic statement you want
to hear but guess what happened they
never went to the championship ever
again and they could have that serious
they actually could have wanted a
championship we could today be saying
that the Pacers were a one-time champion
during that time and LeBron would have
only had two rings instead of his three
but what happened they choked they
didn't make the right decision the
opportunity presented itself did it make
the right decision how does this apply
to you and I you know these weird times
that we're living in with the corona
virus and the pandemic these are very
weird times there's gonna be a very
small community of people I guarantee
you that are sitting around saying I
don't know why I'm optimistic about
something good happening for me around
the corner everybody's telling me it's
the end of the world zombies gonna be
running out here soon
apocalypse Armageddon whatever you want
to call it all these videos going viral
and posing so much fear I think
everything's gonna be all right okay
that small community post pandemic a
crazy opportunity's gonna present itself
to them and they're gonna capitalize but
it's also gonna be a majority of people
in the world who during these times are
gonna get softer they're gonna get
casual they're gonna pick up bad habits
they're gonna watch so much TV they're
probably going to put on five to ten
percent of their body weight gaining 5
10 15 20 pounds of weight just get a
little bit more you know casual with
their energy and that opportunity is
also gonna present itself to those
people but they're not gonna be ready
for it my challenge to you is don't take
these times lightly and get caught and
glued to the TV watching every other
news as if you have any major influence
to be able to slow this thing down
unless if your son
that's directly working with Pharma or
directly working with scientists or
Falchi or the president unless if you're
somebody involved with helping come up
with the cure
keep at it study every single thing
that's going on but if you're not this
is a very good time to recreate yourself
so when that great opportunity presents
itself you capitalize
[Music]